Rappaport's on the phone oh dear I'm
sorry it's okay
all right let's let's see where he's at
maybe he might maybe wants to apologize
maybe that could happen No apologize for
what I mean the songs charting it's a
fantastic it's not it's not charting
anywhere it's real vicious but it is a
funny song it's real shitty his wife
[ __ ] [ __ ] me
France ugly t-shirt I just got one
question can i was getting the answer to
one crime why did you start with me to
begin with
what was this darn brand why in all
seriousness just because you're being a
little [ __ ] [ __ ] you're the biggest
[ __ ] on the planet Howard yeah how
tough the presses Michael recorded a new
song and it'll be upper fronting at
about 10 seconds Michael what do you
call this song and what is this about is
called intergalactic ugly and then
consumed with my work I gotta be honest
with you our it was leaked in northern
Korea and it's starting in northern
Korea right let's get to it so not funny
here is Michael Rapaport has written a
second song about Brent Brent he's got
two songs up on you but we're waiting
for yours I'm sure it's gonna be just as
shitty as the first one there we go kids
ass then he can suck me yeah Brett your
life is one big fail your stories are
tales your jokes are stale you couldn't
get nailed in a shower gel because you
look like a soup on a garbage pail
practice go send Domino's we all [ __ ] is
s then he can suck me and break this
kiss-ass then he can suck me yeah you
[ __ ] your story's a steamie all right
steamy is a pile of [ __ ] you [ __ ] dog
you you look like Darth Vader when they
took his mask off you [ __ ] animal you
oh you want to fight someone start with
your parents you [ __ ] mistake they
never should have had you you look like
Uncle Fester [ __ ] the bar of soap you
[ __ ] you well those are pretty strong
world again another Beastie Boys 1 and
nobody in here laughed because it was
real shitty just trying to hear the
lyrics yeah
really white boy rapping terrible
alright uh Mike keep keep keep hip-hop
and rapping out of your mouth you know
nothing about it I know that you're
terrible at it that's a lesson I
definitely can hear that I got ears I
can tell that you're real shitty Jerry
what was the opinion in the back office
what's going on back there it was
laughter I mean that's the reason why we
chose the Beastie Boys is because of his
beastly faith this guy with with liver
spots on its face is talking about
people's looks and you're going but
you're going bald ooh the Ron Popeil
spray-on hair is not working we sold up
from scraps of a dumpster you [ __ ]
Muppet who wrote that for you well the
beauty's continuing I thought that
Michael might call in and say look let's
call it off but I just want to know the
date that we can get in the Octagon I'm
just waiting for that I don't know if
that's happening Michael you interested
in fighting Brent at all thank you
[ __ ] dummy nobody's fighting we were
opposed to see this not if I let me
Clemmy France let me translate I'm a
[ __ ] and I'm scared that's what you're
saying you make me you make me it's
unfortunate I don't like to see friends
of mine fighting but well if you had to
pick sides what are you gonna do my side
is the radio show and this is golden
Elisabeth a [ __ ] all day